do you think it almost relieves the
filmmaker of some pressure if they are
sort of able to come down from a lofty
ivory tower and meet and after just a
sort of an artist artists you know when
and you almost feel like this great
expectation placed on you to be this
great thing and does it almost relieved
you look almost no that's what it's all
about it because I can't deal with that
pressure yeah I give I have to pretend I
have all the answers not only is it
going to be clear very soon that I don't
have all the answers but I just can't I
also don't enjoy it also don't really
enjoy the auditioning process because if
I'm always making sure there is no table
this whole there's a table between us
and i am the authority and you're the
girl i just don't like it cousin and
it's if i can ask questions it's so much
easier because suddenly I'm it's almost
the lazy way of doing stuff but I don't
actually have to come up with all the
answers but I can justify it I think
directing is all about asking the right
questions and getting interesting people
to give you inspiring answers no thought
maybe whereas if I had to describe
directing all that approach at directing
one sentence that would be and it just
half of my work that's expecting of you
suddenly I don't have to do any more
right and really believes the pressure
on little sleep at night otherwise
is there a perfect filmmaker temperament
personality type
you know what the accountants maybe a
type-a personality is probably more
suited to them because then they're very
on top of numbers and making sure
they're correct what about fulfillment I
don't think there is i mean if i if i
watch behind the scenes footage of some
of my favorite filmmakers they don't
seem to be unfortunately like a
very electric dictators basically so
there's evidence that that kind of
filmmaking works but I think there are
also people we're talking about that do
have a vision need everyone to exactly
fulfill their part and the whole thing
and then some of the people that I know
personally are the the softest nicest
most introverted people in the world
that are not Type A personalities at all
and they make some of the most beautiful
movies you know because they allow
everyone to breathe and everyone to
contribute you know life so I don't
think there is one one personality that
is better suited for directly media I
think Oh a lot of the stuff you're doing
as directors politics unfortunately it
is
impressing producers walking into a room
and that's a whole different game
because they want to have the feeling
that you have a vision but this is
nothing I would ever do in a meeting
with producers asking questions and a
meeting with producers is not
necessarily something that they will
value highly they want someone who's in
charge who basically takes it off their
hands and goals and runs for them so
that's a different thing and I have a
lot of friends that are way better
directors then I am no doubt about it
but they are introverts so they have
problems selling themselves in meetings
with producers so they don't they don't
get the first step down actually getting
the project you know that'd be
incredible on set but they'll never make
it to set with a budget at least you
know
because they can't get past that first
ruble so for that kind of politic the
politics there's probably a personality
takes it that makes easier for you to
that done
you